I'm also impressed by this decision you
made you were a hardworking guy you're a
bodybuilder people didn't know who you
were yet you hadn't done con of the
Barbarian Jack Lane comes to you and
says hey man I'll give you $200,000 to
represent jacal Lane jyms I think
99.9% of the people would have said yes
where do you get the balls and
wherewithal to do that to turn down that
kind of money how do you know well I
tell you that when uh the CEO of the
gymnasium chain came to me and he said
Arnold you know I know you take business
classes you're going to go for a
business degree and you're a bodybuilder
you're into fitness you have run a gym
before in Munich we would like to offer
you this to manage all of our gymnasiums
you will be the perfect person and also
you be the face of the gymnasium chain
right along with Jack the lane and be
offer you
$200,000 you know I thought about it and
I said to myself wait a minute my goal
is is to be a leading man in movies and
to be another Clint Eastwood and Charles
Bronson this were the big stars at that
time that got a million dollars a movie
I want to make a million dollars a movie
I want to shoot for that
goal so if I take this job then I make
$200,000 which is fantastic I can invest
it in real estate and all this stuff I
said but then I have to work 10 hours 12
hours a day and therefore I cannot go
and study
acting I cannot do all the stuff that I
need to do to take voice lessons and
accent removal lessons and acting
lessons and stunt lessons and all this
and then when someone offers me a part I
cannot go and just take off from the
office instead working on a movie set so
no I cannot take this job no matter how
much money it is I cannot take this job
so I had a very clear vision of where I
wanted to go with my acting career so I
felt kind of like this is in my way it
this will be a side thing that it would
take me away from my main goal and so
therefore I just said look I really
appreciate you having that much faith in
me I will help you with promoting the
gymnasium chain I do anything that I I
can but I have to pursue my acting
career and I got to go and put my five
six hours a day into building myself up
as a leading man rather than being a
gymnasium operator or a CEO of a company
like
that